amber heard started only fans did you
see that did you really no
what do you think about uh the verdict
well i think it was probably um good for
all people who believe in the truth and
the problem is there's like this boys
versus girls narrative that i think we
all get into on these things a lot of
guys who wanted a guy to win one of
these things but it's just not good to
not be honest if you're doing that and
you're doing it to try to hurt someone
like if you're purposely changing
reality you're lying about what happened
just to try to hurt somebody you're
doing a [__] up thing because you're
pretending you're a victim you're
turning someone into a criminal you're
pretending you're a victim and it's if
it's all not true it's a really bad
thing yeah it's really bad it's just bad
for all of us yeah it's just not good to
do [__] like that
[Music]